- [Narrator:] This fall…
watch one man
attempt the impossible.
- [Together:] BOOOO.
- Running backs aren’t an optimal position anymore!
- I'm going to break the rushing record, record.
- But you'll have one more game than Eric Dickerson. It'll have an asterisk!
- MY WHOLE CAREER’S HAD AN ASTERISK.
- Derrick Henry can never be a professional running back.
He’s far too big and strong!
- AHHHH!
- Derrick, stop stiff-arming. You’re scaring the other children at the University of Alabama.
- [Narrator:] Watch him buck the projections.
- Look, we come from a long line of Oilers. That’s all we’ll ever be.
So just hide the fact that you’re 6'3", 240 pounds and be a normal back.
- [Narrator:] And inspire us...
Wait, wh—what’s this?
- It’s a tweet from Adam Schefter.
Titans RB Derrick Henry suffered a potentially season-ending—
- Oh, no. Oh, OK, Derrick’s hurt.
OH, NO, WHAT THE HELL? DERRICK'S BASICALLY THE WHOLE TEAM.
- What are you doing?
- I’M SORRY. I’M TRYING TO STIFF-ARM LIKE DERRICK, BUT IT’S HARD.
- Rapoport also has it. Now it’s real.
- Sorry, family only.
- Can't you see? I'm his brother.
- Oh, no, no. No, I’m not.
- He’s very clearly not.
- [Narrator:] OK, uh, the story of...of Ryan.
- IF YOU WANNA WIN SO BAD, WIN.
- I’M GONNA TRY TO WIN.
- GOOD, WE ARE IN TOTAL AGREEMENT.
- You watching Derrick’s high school tape?
- No…this was Derrick playing this year’s Buffalo Bills.
- [Narrator:] Critics are calling it…
With Saquon Barkley.
- You wanna know what the best part of my day is?
Driving up to the Giants facility and hoping no one is there.
- [Narrator:] Najee Harris.
- [Loudspeaker:] Najee, we’re tripling your production.
- But I'm just a rookie!
- [Narrator:] Whoever’s playing running back for the Ravens.
And introducing Cordarrelle Patterson...
- I’M A RECEIVER. BACKS GET USED AND ABUSED.
- [Narrator:] And Cordarrelle Patterson.
- I’M A RUNNING BACK. WE CAN PLAY INTO OUR 30s NOW.
- [Narrator:] Watch Tannehill...become a Tanne-MOUNTAIN.
- They say he could only be out for, like, six weeks!
WOOOOH!
♪♪♪
- [Narrator:] Gridiron Heights presents...
Remember the Titan...Out now and out indefinitely.
- Any other division we'd be done, so thank God for you guys.
- Oh, ya, totally.
- Ya, you got this man.
- My lawyer's advised me not to say anything.
- And from the makers of Remember the Titan…
Comes the story of the rag-tag Cleveland Browns in...
- Sorry, it’s just me. We’re all taking turns being hurt.